[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره قال البنتاجون
ان هو اصطدم مؤشرات على تحرك الروسيين في
خيرسون واستبعد اي استعداد من موسكو
للتراجعي عن المقاطعه الاوكرانيه وبينما
امرت نصف السحابها من مركز المقاطعه
وانشاء خطي دفاعا على ضفه نهر الديبرو قال
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه
لا تزال في المدينه مؤكدا ان انسحابها
يحتاجوا لاسبوع على الاقل
اعدلها سالولات هو المتحده مساعده الابنيه
اضافيه لاوكرانيا قيمتها 400 مليون دولار
كما اعلن البنتاجون تزويد اوكرانيا باربع
منظمات من صواريخ افنجر للدفاع الجوي
ومواصله تقييم الحاجه لصواريخ استنكر
تعهد وزراء دفاع دول القوى الاستكشافيه
المشتركه لدول البلطيق بدعم اوكرانيا
عسكريا وماديا الى حين انتهاء الحرب
الروسيه عليها وقال الوزراء ان روسيا خسرت
الحرب في اوكرانيا
لكنها ما زالت تشكل تحديدا لدول المجموعه
قال المنسق الرئاسي هو الامريكي الخاص
طعام الساقين ان روسيا فشلت في تحقيق
هدفهامي الى استخدام الطاقه سلاحا وكسر
وحده الولايات المتحده واوروبا واسيا
في لقاء خاص مع الجزيره ان ذلك تحقق لان
واشطا عملت عن كثب مع دول مثل قطر للحصول
على امدادات بديله
تتواصلوا عمليه فرز الاصوات في الانتخابات
النصفيه
وتشير اخر الارقام الى تقدم الحزب
الجمهوري في مجلس النواب واحتلال
المنافستي في مجلس الشيوخ وفي حين حصل
الجمهوريون على 200 واحد 10 مقعدا مقابل
190 الى الديمقراطيين في مجلس النواب خاصه
الجمهوريون على 49 وقعدا مقابله 48
الديمقراطيين في مجلس الشيوخ
وستهددون نتائج ولايات
نيفادانا وجورجيا من سيفوز بالمجلس
قال رئيس الامريكي جو بايتين ان الشعب
الامريكي دعم بقوه اجنده ادارته باعاده
بناء الولايات المتحده اضاف بيض انه لم
تتوضح كل نتائج بعد ولكن حزبه خسر اقل عدد
من المقاعد في مجلس النواب مقارنه مع اي
رئيس سابق
اعدادات الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
وعدم تسجيل اي تقدم في المحادثات مع ايران
بشان العثور على اثاره على اثار مواد
النوويه في ثلاثه مواقع غير معلن عنها
وقالت اسال وكاله ان ايران تواصل زياده
مخزونها من اليورانيوم عالي التخصيب
هذا المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
لابراهيم ان الايرانيين زادوا مخزونهم من
اليورانيوم المخصب واعرب برايه واشنطن
بشان عدم وجوده تقدمه في حاله قضيه مخزون
ايران داعيا الايرانيين الى الاجابه عن
الاسئله الوكاله والتعاون معها
من جهتي قال وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين
الامير عبد الله هيام ان الحوارات
والتعاون التقني بين صهران والوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه يمضي في مسار مناسب
مشاهد انتهى المجسم